Hey guys! We are in Asakusa, Tokyo, right now, as you can see.
Today, we would like to take you...
...to the super popular okonomiyaki place near Asakusa.
Even though okonomiyaki in Osaka is more well-known,...
...the restaurant we're going is really in demand.
So let's go and check it out.
On the way going to the restaurant, we see this amazing Sensoji temple,...
...which is one of Tokyo's oldest temples.
It is the most popular attraction...
...among both Japanese locals and foreign visitors.
Japan's temples are famous for their vivid history and unique decoration,...
...and at Sensoji, you are always able to find delicious local snacks...
...and interesting Japanese souvenirs.